[Música]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestra red de periodistas
soy arminia Fernández por Andrés espinal
han pasado más de 18 meses desde que los
talibanes tomaron el poder en Afganistán
muchas mujeres africanas se han visto
privadas de la enseñanza secundaria y
superior después que el régimen talibán
prohibiera el acceso a las niñas a los
institutos y universidades hace unos
pocos días los internautas afganos le
pidieron a elon musk director general de
spacex y propietario de Twitter que
introduzca su servicio de internet por
satélite starling en Afganistán como ya
hizo en Ucrania e Irán veamos el informe
de qualaf y Sonia
hace cinco meses que Marian continúa sus
estudios en la sala de su casa después
de que los talibanes prohibieran la
educación Universitaria a las niñas esta
ex estudiante universitaria de 21 años
recibe clases de inglés en su teléfono a
través de WhatsApp según el calendario
hoy tienes que trabajar la gramática las
instrucciones sean mediante mensajes
fotos videos y notas de voz paga el
equivalente a 5 dólares al mes por el
curso además tiene que pagar una
conexión a internet débil y cara
Este es un vídeo que me ha enviado la
profesora pero no puedo descargarlo
porque la conexión a internet es muy
mala lo único que puedo descargar son
mensajes de voz
cuando estudiaba en la universidad Tenía
muchos sueños y esperanzas pensaba que
continuaría mis estudios pero hoy no
tengo ninguna Esperanza
como muchas otras mujeres afganas en las
redes sociales Pide a elon musk you
spacex y propietario de Twitter que
ponga su servicio de internet por
satélite starlink a disposición de
Afganistán Como hizo en Ucrania e Irán
esta petición de las mujeres afganas a
elon musk que está motivada por el hecho
de que muchas de nosotras no tenemos
acceso a internet a veces es por los
problemas económicos que tiene nuestras
familias apoyó esta petición y sin los
respondieran positivamente Me alegraría
mucho
los talibanes afirman que las jóvenes
podrán volver a estudiar algún día sin
embargo exigen la segregación total en
los centros educativos según el director
de una universidad privada será una
tarea difícil que aumentara los gastos
de la universidad
tenemos problemas financieros Por que un
tercio de los estudiantes no están
principios de curso no pudimos
matricular a ninguna mujer digan manos
en el mejor de los casos Si seres
autoriza a volver en algún momento
estarán en un edificio separado en
clases separadas con profesores
exclusivos lo que aumentará aún más
nuestros gastos
[Música]
por ahora las afganas no tienen más
opciones que estudiar en casa o en
escuelas secretas
en Ecuador
el resear más a civiles ha dividido a la
población uno se han inclinado a tomar
clases de tiro para aprender a
manejarlas y otros aseguran que permitir
el uso de armamento generará más
violencia en el país nuestro
corresponsal Gustavo Ortega nos trae la
historia
Patricio Barragán comenzó a asistir a
prácticas Se tiró al blanco el
incremento de la criminalidad en Ecuador
y la nueva ley que permite el porte de
armas lo ha motivado a entrenarse para
estar preparado ante un eventual suceso
que ponga en riesgo su vida yo espero
nunca estar en medio de algún
algún alguno de esos eventos Pero bueno
entre todo eso prepararse no está de más
perfecto Te felicito José bastidas es un
experto en el manejo de armas tras la
medida decretada por el ejecutivo
ecuatoriano recibe centenares de
llamadas de nuevos aspirantes que
quieren aprender a disparar el decreto
exige contar con 25 años de edad no
tener antecedentes penales y denuncias
por violencia familiar y justificar la
tenencia de un arma Entonces esto
realmente ha motivado a las personas
pero también con esto la delincuencia
también va a poner en alerta
no solo los civiles están tomando la
iniciativa de Aprender a usar armas Los
vigilantes de seguridad como Miguel
también deben tener una preparación en
uso de armamento porque según la medida
gubernamental ahora serán apoyo de la
Policía Nacional si usted no utiliza
alarma le pueden salir como Cómplices no
sino que queda como un guarda ya en
epecto que no no pudo hacer bien su
trabajo algo y si lo utilizamos Claro
que tenemos podemos enfrentar cargos con
la justicia
preocupa el psiquia Fernando Cornejo el
experto asegura que los Ecuatorianos
sufren de paranoia ante el estado de
inseguridad y armarlos generaría más
violencia si se enfrentan a una eventual
reacción en defensa personal vamos a
llamarle porque es una conducta
desadaptativa en general de la población
y esto nos puede llevar a que no
tengamos los filtros suficientes para
poder generar una situación de defensa
datos oficiales señala que en el año
2021 se produjeron 1081
muertes violentas en el año 2022 se
incrementó a 2.521 y en los tres
primeros meses de 2023 la Policía
Nacional ya lleva contabilizadas 1356
asesinatos los cristales amenazan las
principales zonas de protección de
Tegucigalpa la capital de Honduras el
grueso de las deflagraciones Ha arrasado
con miles hectáreas de bosques las
autoridades forestales han denunciado
que algunos de estos incendios son
provocados por pirómanos y por la ola de
calor que se registra en esta época de
verano una de las zonas más afectadas es
el parque nacional la tira considerado
el pulmón de la capital unidades
ambientalistas del instituto de
conservación forestal secretaría del
ambiente bomberos ejército y voluntarios
trabajan contrarreloj para detener las
llamas nuestra corresponsal Kenia Torres
estuvo en una de las zonas cero y este
es su reporte
Sandra canales lidera el equipo de
protección forestal que realiza labores
de combate contra los incendios
forestales que están Arrasando los
terrenos en zonas protegidas de
Tegucigalpa este incendio pues está
dentro de un área protegida si bien es
cierto Está en un área de
amortiguamiento como se lo menciona pero
es parte de un área protegida es un área
de Gran importancia ecológica verdad
para la ciudad capital
ya que son zonas de recarga Además del
interés ecológico por la flora y fauna
unos 100 miembros del equipo
especializado del ejército atacan el
incendio desde otro flanco según
investigaciones los quirómanos y el
ardiente verano son las principales
causas de las quemas este momento se
está haciendo una ronda de prevención
para posteriormente realizar el
contrafuego y poder liquidar este
incendio que de gran magnitud pese a las
campañas de prevención según las
autoridades en lo que va del 2023
823 incendios forestales han consumido
unas 50.000 hectáreas de bosque estamos
trabajando desde el mes de noviembre
gracias al aumento del presupuesto
operativo del icf para la parte de
protección forestal en actividades de
prevención forestal como quemas
prescritas para reducir El combustible
evitar la propagación del fuego rondas
cortafuegos cinturones negro
capacitación de personal el devastador
panorama se registra el medio de una ola
de calor y ha provocado que la capital
esté envuelta en una densa capa de humo
los expertos esperan que la temporada de
incendios llegue a su fin con el inicio
de las lluvias el próximo mes de mayo
Colombia es uno de los seis países de
América Latina que albergan cerca del
95% del total de casos semalarias
registrados en la región en el selvático
departamento del chocó en el Pacífico la
media de casos de paludismo ha crecido
un 60% en los últimos 30 años
condiciones medioambientales así como la
pobreza la falta de recursos básicos de
protección o actividades como la minería
ilegal hacen que la malaria siga
conviviendo en la cotidianidad de las
comunidades una enfermedad que intentan
atajar desde todos los estamentos de
salud locales Marta Moya y aitor
chavarri tienen más detalles en el
siguiente reportaje
en el pequeño corregimiento de tu nendo
virgelina salas lleva 20 años atendiendo
a pacientes con malaria en este año van
153 pacientes con malaria Esta
microscopista visita analiza y hace el
seguimiento de todas las personas que
llegan a su consulta con síntomas
compatibles
Entonces ya si les ha dolido la cabeza
si han tenido un escalofrío si le ha
dolido el estómago si han tenido un
dolor de espalda si les ha dado fiebre
pasan a tomarse la muestra este niño de
nueve años debe hacerse la prueba en
unas horas sabrá si es positivo en
malariado tu turendo es una de las
localidades más afectadas de Colombia
las condiciones medioambientales así
como la minería ilegal son factores de
riesgo en el departamento del chocó en
la costa pacífica los casos han subido
cerca de un 60% en los últimos 30 años
mientras la media nacional se mantiene a
la baja sin embargo el paludismo no solo
se da en contexto Rurales en quibdó la
capital departamental esta problemática
también persiste
alguien está pendiente para el
diagnóstico La microscopista Tomasa
Santos recibe cada día a un goteo
constante de personas en el laboratorio
en este hospital local la universidad de
Antioquia desarrolla un programa de
investigación sobre paludismo en busca
de una posible vacuna esta mañana llegó
John Arley un minero de 19 años que ya
ha pasado la enfermedad en 8 ocasiones
no da mucha protección uno atrae por la
necesidad porque no hay más Poco después
de hacerse la prueba llegan los
resultados Este joven nuevamente tiene
malaria Y esa especie que tú tienes
ellos tienden a dejarlos en los oídos en
el hígado aún te tomes todo el
medicamento O sea que tiene que ser más
juicioso que lo que tú no te imaginas
él promete que se tomará el tratamiento
pero pronto volverá a la mina
en el estudio de la malaria en el chocó
cooperan todos los estamentos locales de
salud en el laboratorio departamental
comprueban la calidad del testeo no con
el control de calidad nosotros lo que
hacemos Es que garantizamos que esa
bacterióloga sea idónea para dar un buen
resultado al paciente aquí trabajan
junto al equipo de entomología encargado
de analizar las particularidades del
insecto mirar el comportamiento del
mosquito su taxonomía cómo se comporta
cuáles son sus sitios donde se crían
Cuáles son los sitios más vulnerables
que él pueda tener una labor conjunta
para atajar la malaria en la región más
afectada de Colombia un país donde se
siguen presentando más de 70.000 casos
anuales
hasta que corresponsales de la semana
hoy desde la Feria Internacional del
Libro de Bogotá
en formación en Francia 24.com